nicolas glières professeur de français à
paris administrateur du mouvement est
les stylos rouges
bonjour à vous merci d'avoir accepté de
répondre en direct à nos questions sur
rt france 86 % des écoles qui sont
censés reprendre leur sens de la marche
la semaine prochaine c'est une reprise
nécessaire ou bien vous êtes en
désaccord avec cette mesure
la reprise n'est pas du tout nécessaire
elle est nécessaire en septembre elle
est nécessaire à la rentrée là il n'y a
plus aucun intérêt à le faire ont fait
le travail en distanti l on le fait bien
on le fait comme on peut et la reprise
est dangereuse il suffit de voir dans la
vienne ce qui s'est passé vous en ai
parlé tout à l'heure
dans la vienne une réunion complètement
inutile de neuf adultes a eu lieu
bam la moitié est malade alko vide donc
ça c'est un avant goût de ce qui va se
passer partout
vu qu'on était tous continuer on était
protégé pas seulement du côté de mai
d'autres maladies
là on va tous tombés malades les enfants
les adultes et notamment du coc vide
donc c'est un une illustration parfaite
de ce qu'on dénonce depuis très
longtemps de ce qu'on dit depuis très
longtemps et être cassandre c'est pas
très amusant ça n'a aucun intérêt car on
ferait mieux de nous écouter et non
demande vraiment gouvernement de
réfléchir et de ne pas rouvrir les
écoles de laisser les choses telles
qu'elles sont elles se passe
suffisamment correctement on n'a pas
besoin de les rouvrir
on imagine que c'est une situation
difficile à gérer pour tous les
enseignants
on comprends votre inquiétude mais sur
quels points
vous avez des craintes précisément pas
exactement ce qui vient de se passer
dans la vienne c'est à dire que les
enfants sont des vecteurs
asymptomatiques ils vont contaminer tout
le monde
eux ne sont pas en danger la plupart du
temps ce qui rassure malheureusement
j'allais dire les parents en gros quand
celle quand les enfants ne sont pas
touchés on s'en moque
les adultes peuvent bien mourir c'est
pas très grave ben nous on trouve ça
grave on n'a pas envie de mourir ou
tombés malades
on n'a pas envie de contaminer nos
proches ou n'a pas envie non plus que
les familles des élèves sont malades ou
meurent parfois d'un c'est complètement
irresponsable en fait ce qui se passe on
voit qu'on est encore traités comme des
cobayes concrètement on a entendu tout à
l'heure jean michel blanquer a expliqué
que faire des tests pour les enseignants
c'était du gâchis
donc voilà toute la considération qu'il
a pour nous méprise il n'a aucune estime
pour nos nous tester c'est gâcher les
tests c'est incroyable c'est juste la
preuve d'un mépris total à l'égard des
personnels d'éducation
tous autant qu'ils sont donc ce que vous
dites c'est que les conditions d'une
reprise dès demain pour les enseignants
pour les élèves ne sont pas réunies
alors elles ne sont pas réunies du tout
encore une fois la vienne on a la preuve
pour le co mais pas seulement c'est à
dire qu'on nous demande dans tous les
cas les garanties que qui devraient être
respectées pour assurer notre sécurité
et celle des familles 7 des élèves sont
des garanties hospitalière mais l'école
n'est pas un hôpital où il faut quand
même rappeler aux gens quand ton prof on
n'a pas signé pour être des militaires
qui vont mourir au combat ou des
personnels d'hôpital qui risquent leur
santé on a déjà assez de problèmes à
l'école comme ça pour rend plus rajouter
des critères d'autres métiers on n'a pas
signé pour tomber malade
on n'a pas signé pour gérer une épidémie
on n'a pas signé non plus pour avoir des
conditions de travail hospitalière à se
laver les mains jusqu'aux coudes dix
fois par jour le haut niveau matériel
joueuses heures imaginées emmener des
petits huit fois par jour dont des
toilettes dans lesquelles il ya deux
lavabos et trois toilettes 7,1 faisable
les gestes barrière ne seront pas
respectés
les buts ils ne respectent pas les ados
contre ce sera leur tour de rôle de 18
pour certains collèges pas si nombreux
que ça ça va être pareil ça va être
extrêmement compliqué ça ne sera pas
respectée concrètement les cavs auraient
explosé
exactement comme ça se passe dans le
nord de l'allemagne en corée au japon et
autres
et ensuite on se dire ah ben zut les
gens ont rattrapé le coup vide
les chiffres remontent mais c'est une
évidence et jean michel blanquer qui
souhaitent
on l'a dit est que chaque enfant
reviennent au moins à l'école avant la
fin de mai pour le ministre je le cite
la première priorité à l'aide
psychologique accueillir les élèves les
écouter voir comment ils vont sur ce
point là encore je voudrais votre avis
alors sa phrase est merveilleuse qu'ils
reviennent une fois d'ici fin mai ça
veut dire qu'on met tout ce bazar en
place dangereux pour tout le monde
insiste là-dessus pour que des enfants
viennent une demi-journée ou une journée
sur un mois de qui se moque t'on le
prétexte était la lutte contre les
inégalités on sait très bien que les
décrocheurs notamment vous viendront pas
donc là en plus on n'est même plus
l'être dans le prétexte ne tient même
plus un jour sur tout le mois de mai
comment les parents pourront ils aller
au travail c'était l'autre grand
argument avec les inégalités si c'est un
jour ils pourront aller au travail quoi
un jour et donc on fait tout ce bazar
pour qu'il retourne un jour physiquement
sur un lieu de travail
soyons sérieux monsieur blanc car ne
l'est pas il est dans une obsession dans
une idéologie il veut la réouverture il
ne voulait pas de la fermeture ou la
force et a fermé mais il ne voulait pas
il a été désavoué par monsieur macro il
a été désavoué par monsieur philippe il
recommence ce une espèce de folie
il veut rouvrir peu importe que ça coûte
peu importe que sacré comme catastrophe
sanitaire
en tout cas il en est responsable et
nous on le rendra responsables lui et
toutes les personnes qui nous menacent
qu'ils nous intimident pour reprendre
ils sont responsables pénalement ces
gens c'est vrai que la communication
gouvernementale depuis le début de cette
épidémie elle pose beaucoup de questions
et encore cette déclaration de
jean-michel blanquer qui concerne
justement à l'est les écoliers il dit
que l'école ne serait pas une garderie
est ce que c'était une précision
nécessaire ce que c'est un faux pas
selon alors c'est notre leitmotiv depuis
très longtemps depuis un an et demi est
rappelé aux parents à la société à notre
ministère que enseigner c'est un métier
que je n'ai pas gardé des enfants ça n'a
rien à voir on n'est pas là pour arrogé
les gens on n'est pas là pour garder les
enfants pendant qu'ils vaquent à leurs
occupations professionnelles ou
personnelles
on est là pour leur transmettre des
connaissances pour un échange en classe
quand on peut actuellement hors de la
classe
et c'est un essentiel comme principe
l'école n'est pas une garderie
l'hôpital n'est pas une garderie qui ré
demandait aux hospitaliers garder des
enfants
et bien c'est la même chose c'est pas
parce qu'on s'occupe d'élèves la journée
qu'on ait des animateurs ce qui n'a
aucun mépris pour le métier d'animateur
mais ce n'est pas notre métier on est
professeur une enseigne ou transmettre
des connaissances
l'école n'est pas là pour garder des
enfants quelle que soit la situation
donc il ya vraiment un gros problème de
positionnement de la part de notre
hiérarchie du ministère et des parents
d'élèves et ce depuis toujours c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut vraiment
changer le monde d'après moi j'espère
vraiment qu'il prendra en compte le fait
que l'école n'est pas une garderie par
exemple merci beaucoup nicolas glières
je rappelle que vous êtes professeur de
français à paris administrateur du
mouvement les stylos roches martiennes
merci à vous